probably birth other than that I'm sorry
other than that I would say let's see
well we went to the Grand Canyon and you
know just being me and just hopping
around jump around just climbing up
basically we were right at the edge of
the camp and we were climbing up this
one wall and I told him that was a
really stupid way to go up this rock
formation and he said the verbatim what
are we gonna do fall off the Grand
Canyon barely caught himself other than
that he would have felt right in that
whatever that big old hole in the ground
also for a nice adorable answer being
with someone you love well you know it's
family but also friends oh absolutely
get in here
I feel the most alive when I am
performing drag when I have the wig and
the heels on and my songs on and that
crowds really feeling it and I'm feeling
them that's when I feel most alive I
don't even know honestly it's just one
of those things I just don't question it
and probably when I'm with my
girlfriends I'm actually gonna propose
today so I was thinking I might be
coming I knew it would be when he was
here visiting but I didn't know who's
gonna be today so he was trying really
hard to find the perfect spot and take a
picture and I was kind of like why being
so weird about this but it makes sense
when he got down I was like no way
trying to find a good spot so we could
actually have pictures of it I was
mountain boarding down this leg like
this massive hill and I hit this rock
and I just fly off the board and I just
see like the whole ground beneath me I'm
just flying at it and I'm just like I am
probably going to die right now and I
felt kind of amazing for a little bit
and then I hit the ground and then I
felt awful but but probably that moment
running with the Bulls in Pamplona it
was that closest to dying that I've ever
been
that's the muscle I've I've ever felt as
well so yeah when I finally cut my hair
off I felt free you know because a lot
of people are very attached to their
hair and it's just like I can let it go
I don't need it to add Beauty because
I'm beautiful about it
it's a good question
I have a lot of depression so it's kind
of muddled everything recently I
celebrated my death I've earmarked a
stop self-harming and that is it's
really freeing not to do that number
when I saw the urges but that's not as
bad and he takes time I would have to
say I'm pretty shy person I don't really
like I given this is out of my comfort
zone but I think the most time that I
felt alive was like doing spoken word
and poetry I think the most time I felt
life was the first time that I did it I
didn't expect the reaction that I was
going to get and a lot of people liked
it was really a Stoke that a lot of
people really
happy to hear me this could go feel like
I should feel alive more often just
being around my nieces and nephews it's
probably when I do feel most alive like
they're just so innocent and young and
they do they're alive at every moment
whereas I have to think really hard
about when the last time that I was
alive was were felt alive so I think I
also just love him so much when you feel
that much love for just like some young
kids that are so innocent that there's
just something super beautiful about
that we should learn how to do that as
adults when I was in school I like had
this group of friends that I would
always just like drive around with they
got nights and like one time we were
just like we were just driving in the
middle of the night and my friend like
stuck his head completely out of the
window and I was like what are you doing
like reminded me of like a dog like
sticking the head up but then I was like
I want to try it and I tried it you know
so pretty and like it felt like the air
felt really good and I feel like that
was like the Tyler were like what I
think of a lot that I felt was a lie
pretty much now you know getting to be
with my friends so what about it makes
you feel alive do you think just being
getting out more than I usually do
I went on a trip about a year ago and I
I had paid for the trip for the first
time all by myself and I organized the
whole thing and so I think I felt most
alive that time because I did pretty
much most of it on my own and I took a
group of my friends but I made sure that
it was all taken care of so we went to
all the amusement parks and while
everyone was tired by the end of it I
was like yeah that was great to see I
could accomplish that
so the moment I felt most alive was the
day that my son was born and so it was
really interesting because he wouldn't
cry he was it was had just given birth I
had a c-section and I had just given
birth and he wouldn't cry and who I'm
crying right
and so finally it seemed like an
eternity until he like just whimpered
right and it was like a like a tiny
little cry and that was the moment that
my heart just exploded and became like
four times the size it was before right
because I had so much love for this
little this little crying whimpering
baby and it was so amazing so that was
the moment in my life that I felt most
alive probably one time when I was
riding my bicycle alone
because I don't know I'm normally like a
homebody and not a lot to do many things
by myself so I don't know I felt free
because I could just be myself and like
it wasn't held back by anyone and I can
go wherever I wanted I was probably
around seven or eight my granddad had
built my sister and I like a little cart
that we could drive ourselves and I
don't know when you're seven and eight
it feels like you're untouchable and we
were driving down this fast road where
cars go 90 and it was just like a
liberating feeling being so young and I
don't know it felt it felt amazing
and it touches me every time because I
just lost my granddad a few years ago so
it's a good memory time oh god I think
in my trip to Iceland being like I think
in that moment but feeling like the
presence of God like I'm not super
religious and I'm you know I love God
and everything but I just I felt like he
was there because of the tremendous pace
that I had with like the environment and
the mountains and just everything was so
perfect when I was dead what happened
exactly
yeah well I became one with everything
and I didn't exist as just a singular
person anymore
and it was beautiful I think the time I
felt most alive was when I decided to do
what I wanted to do with my life instead
of what everybody else wanted me to do
with my life and I want to start a
swimsuit business and what did everyone
else want you right now I'm studying
math biology and chemistry I was
supposed to be a bioengineer very
capable of still being a bioengineer but
I'm choosing the life I want so I really
embarassingly went out and bought a
self-help book which was the first time
I'd ever done that and I was like oh my
gosh this is so cringy it was the yellow
badass book and I read it cover to cover
and I was like wow I needed to
reevaluate I'd live my whole life by
other people's terms and it was time to
live it by mine so I decided that I
wanted to go out and start my own
business and donate money back to
different people in different countries
each limb sue is inspired by a different
country - and I love travelling so that
allows me to incorporate all my passions
well I don't really know how to answer
that question because I used to be more
depressed like back in high school and I
got a type of psychosis is called
cotard's syndrome and I felt dead like
like I really felt dead like sometimes I
would hallucinate and like taste like
like I was dying and I felt like I was
just watching life through like a
third-person perspective like a movie so
I feel like I still kind of feel that
way sometimes but I don't have psychosis
anymore but it's just like you don't
really know what reality is like I don't
feel like very grounded sometimes so I
don't really feel it you would say that
you've never felt the feeling of being
alive I don't know I mean bass like
adrenaline and stuff but it's never like
a full grasp of I am breathing like I
feel very disconnected from body and
mind and spirit so it's a bit hard to
answer when I think about that question
I come up with a memory in my head
that's of me just like laying on my
couch
and I'm just like staring at the ceiling
and during that moment of my life I was
going through like a lot I felt like I
was feeling symptoms of like what it
would like to like be like to have
depression not that I think that I have
depression
because they're people who really do
like have depression and they really do
struggle with it and it's something that
I want to undermine I was just laying
there and I was like I have nothing to
do I have nothing to go do I have like
no purpose I have I'm just laying here
so I felt like really stuck and I felt
like I couldn't control it
so I would just like avoid it and so
when you like avoid everything you you
kind of just feel like what it feels
like just like you you know because like
a lot of people are attached to what
they're doing you know like the things
that they're accomplishing like that's
their life but like having nothing and
feeling like I had no control and
feeling like there was nothing I could
like feel like I had accomplished or
something that I was working towards I
literally just felt like me it's kind of
confused it's like confusing to explain
but I'll try and like get it into one
more cohesive sentence like I'll just
floating you know probably when I picked
up a camera why would you say that just
it helps look at the world in a
different light and different
perspectives
once I started capturing real what I
considered intimate moments there you go
I think I have to agree with you I think
that's all my
awesome everyone before you go I just
wanna let you know that I put together a
playlist of episodes similar to the one
you just watched
so if you like this episode make sure to
check that out it'll be linked somewhere
on the screen I also want to thank
everyone who voted on the polls earlier
this week you have no idea how much that
helps me because I overthink everything
and because I overthink everything
including the questions of the week or
the episode of the week I just want to
make sure that it's something you guys
want to watch so when I put up a poll
and you guys vote it helps a lot I also
just want to thank you guys for
everything it's pretty crazy how far
we've come in just two years and I can't
believe I get to do this every week you
know it's a it's a lot of fun making
these episodes but most of the fun is in
getting to share it with you guys
because you guys are just the coolest
and I love hearing what you have to say
about each episode yeah I can't thank
you guys enough so thank you again
that's pretty much it I'll see you guys
next week
[Music]